[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: So we have a
constant conversation
in society about the role of
technology in the world, right.
Mankind has this capacity
to extend his agency
into these scaffoldings,
into these tools that
are beyond his
biological skin tissue.
We extend our mind,
we're out into the world.
The Mars Rover right now
crawls the surface of Mars,
extending our optic
nerve into space.
That is what we
do with our tools.
And, increasingly, these
tools are giving us
transformation,
disruption, they're
giving us new construction
kits for our reality.
You know, Mark Pesce
has a great line.
He says that advances in
emerging biotechnology,
which gives us the power to
harness the software of life.
And in emerging
technologies of nanotech,
which allow us to pattern
the physical atoms
of the physical
world increasingly
are making the world
linguistically pliable, right.
DNA is code.
The material science
of nanotech allows
us to turn this into
something that can be rendered
at the speed of thought.
This notion of reality, of the
world becoming linguistically
pliable tells us that
mind, okay, that agency,
that sentience has overpowered
the biosphere, the mind sphere,
the noosphere is now a
force of geological impact.
Consider that the
next time you're
sitting a dinner
talking to somebody
about the role of technology.
I mean, it's really like
[LAUGH]
it's the bursting
forth of a new agency,
a new agent of evolution.
We are evolution evolving
its own evolvability, right.
Man, who knows where we're
going to go with that, who
knows what we're going to do.
[MUSIC PLAYING]